one of the nicest people you'll meet and
I would say that even if you were not
sitting directly to my right we'd loved
him in anchorman superior doughnuts on
CBS America's most watched network is
part of the latest part of the big gig
David country's being she was wallowing
the be yes yeah
America's most watched network okay
that's the way Nance does it okay have
you ever heard that yes you know a
gymnast and then and then the guy before
him um summer all he used to pronounce
the comma and Murder She Wrote when he
did the promos coming up later on Murder
She Wrote that's the way he used to do
oh that's also all those were always my
favorite you know hearing Keith Jackson
when he would do the college games you
know coming up tonight on me you know
all new commish you know that sort of
thing I always loved that yeah Jackson
is almost like he used to be a former
race caller yeah doesn't sound like a
hammock that's right where he interned
yeah yeah my favorite one all-time was
when summer all would do the Fox Sports
when he's doing the Fox games and he'd
do the Fox lineup coming up tonight on
house sub buggin Oh
Newhouse uh buggin to say you're here to
talk about more than anything else
raising money for children in need sick
children in need in your native Kansas
City yes it's part of the big slick
charity golf charity tournament bowling
tournament and used to be cards now it's
bowling a celebrity event that's going
down coming up in a couple of weekends
right in Kansas City you and who else
are as well that's our Paul Rudd yes Rob
Riggle Eric Stonestreet Jason Sudeikis
all from Kansas City well starts you
just outside of I'm about hour and a
half from Casey that's where I grew up
so they invited me to be one of the host
members also so we host a big event it's
a big celebrity weekend because we bring
about 25 of our friends to Kansas City
wonderful town you've been there many
times and I thank the credible event in
the right oh it is fun one of the best
parts about it before we dig into it as
well is that you and wriggle and
Sudeikis and Rudd
Stonestreet not only one of everybody
who's there to have fun but you walk up
to everybody who goes there the night
before the visit that we all have to go
to see the kids who we are trying to
help and despite it being midnight 1:00
a.m.
perhaps some spirits are involved you
walk up to us and you're like you point
to your watch 7:30 a.m. you got to be in
the lobby
we are going to see these kids that's
the fan we feel you're your love for for
the event it does make a difference
that's the best part when you do meet
parents because year after year they do
invite parents and use do see where it
makes a difference and and that's that's
it feels good but you know
intellectually like a good we're doing
something to make a difference in the
world which is awesome
but yes we're going to we go we get
there Thursday visit Friday morning the
children at Children's Mercy and
Children's Mercy doesn't turn anybody
away that's the thing if you've got a
kid that's sick and in need come on in
they come from all over the Midwest in
particular but the country as well it's
a world it's a world-class facility
world-class they've got a world-class
research facility too that's made a huge
difference a lot of difference in a lot
of people's lives so I appreciate when
you come in and all our friends come in
but we we go we visit in the morning and
then we get to go to Kauffman Stadium
home of the Royals home of the Royals
World Champion Royals I mean within the
last two years or so yeah but we play
softball now on at Thursday because I
think you come before where we had
little Kauffman little K which is right
behind left field the left field
fountains that I frequently want to jump
into because it's 1,000 degrees outhouse
and especially up there on that little
oil field but now you've moved it to the
actual Diamond Royals are playing on
that night direct and you go out there
and now this time somebody can actually
go to omae's calm slash big slick and
join and well they can they can coach
the team we're going to have two winners
I believe okay and you can be the coach
of we have you know the blue team of the
white team Royals colors and so we're
gonna have two coaches all you got to do
is enter to enter when you make a donate
to Children's Mercy two big slick yes
and now you're entered to win a chance
we'll fly you out put trip for the
weekend you'll participate in all of the
event unbelievable so there's the
softball then we go to the dugout sweet
hang out have a bunch of hotdogs you're
there with all the celebrities then the
next morning we get up visit the kids
again and then we go and have a bowling
tournament tons of celebrities 20 lanes
tons of people buying it the lane to you
no chance to play the celebrity and
raise money for the kids then that night
you're still part of this winner that
night we have a huge auction which you
know is a lot of fun it's an auction and
a show with all of our friends on stage
at the Midland theater beautiful art
deco facility from way back in the day
it's beautiful and that's the who right
that's the well guys I've told you this
you know before that when you say it's a
show you pull people out of the audience
and put them on the stage and all these
celebrities are on the stage with an
open bar on the stage sure if that has
happened to the point where they play
game shows right right there was one
year that I was there a match game
themed game show oh okay so the answer
was something and fill in the blank okay
you know I left my blank at the office
so all of these celebrities would have
to ride in the clue and then the cue
card correct and the person who would
pull it would pull out of the audience
had to answer the question and whoever
can batched more they way to contestant
yeah so I just so you guys understand I
decided you know what I wrote like a
real answer but then I looked around and
I saw some heavy-hitting funny people
like right you read the room hi what I
did I saw you should Tyler who's coming
back this year she's not made just oh
she can't found out she's got all know
she's the busiest person on planet she's
a Knoxville is he is gonna be okay
Johnny Knoxville Martin Starr was coming
back he's you know in Silicon Valley
funny people
so I decided to write the word even
though it really didn't fit I decided to
write the word taint on the card which
great one noun or a verb yes it and so I
decided to do that because figuring
everybody would figure I was the last
guy in the room to work blue right
with Ruud out there and you and
Stonestreet sudeikis so I held that up
and how many people started for the rest
of the night using the same word I
believe that was the only answer and
after it was the only answer for one
night how many other times did the folks
in Kansas City I think that maybe this
was a bad idea of making it what how
many other times have you done the match
game at the big slick sense I will say
after that and I don't want to say
incident to that
like of the show that particular game
show has been discontinued in a way if
you will folks there of of better minds
than mine said this taint happening
again thank you everybody
so again omae's dot-com / big slick as
hell people can come out and be part of
this whole thing and be a VIP and be
part of this this incredible event as to
win and hang out with us all weekend and
one of the things that you didn't
mention that you have done in the past
seventh-inning stretch go out of the
whole thing that's it
I forgot yes of course and also if the
Tigers are in town do you still scream
at Gene Lamont the third-base coach of
the Tigers and Hector him all game long
like I've done in the past whether Gene
Lamont is in town or not yes he will be
mentioned at the end tell that story
real quick okay I wasn't there that year
but it was the first year or second you
were there in first year I was not there
the first year either nope so the first
year I believe it was playing the Tigers
and genes third base coat he was at the
time yeah and Will Ferrell was in that
year as a friend to help raise money and
so they're all in the dugout suite and
basically you're it's basically a dugout
right next to the dugout and they
apparently were taunting Gene Lamont the
entire game and did will not also walk
onto the field
that's like they were relentless in
their teasing I mean was cajoling I
guess would be a better word of Gene
Lamont so now every year they always do
interviews down in the dugout dugout
sweet and June low maja will be brought
up they'll talk about gene and at the
end of the seventh-inning stretch when
we sing take me out to the ballgame
finish it and
a Jean Lamont I'm not sure he knows how
better you know how the take me out to
the ballgame is punctuated each time yes
Gene Lamont Gene Lamont but I will say
the focus at this point from our
celebrity guests is sometimes a bit
loose yes and they might not might not
come off without the proper
clap great use of Eclat David Koechner
I'll take a 60-second break we come back
we'll talk a little bit of the Chiefs as
you're getting set to head to Kansas
City
by the way omae's dot-com / big slick or
you can go to big slick org dot-com to
go and donate to that right or is it big
know it's big split kc.org is how you
can go that's your website you type in
big slick the right thing will come up
there you go
I'll take a 60-second break we'll do
that and then I'd like you to help me be
my friend in a phone a friend type game
always where Kris law is going to it's
going to be me against Brockman he's
going to say the name of an athlete and
that athlete will either have been
somebody was just drafted in the Major
League Baseball Draft oh boy
or a qualifier to the US Open that is
now in the middle of the first round
just by the mere sound of the name
we'll have to guess if he's a golfer or
a baseball play so you don't know either
I have no say yeah I thought can I hold
my son I have no no no I know
earthly idea it's just going by the
sound of the name we're both out of our
depth I feel comfortable man for
instance just like throw out champ kind
does that sound like an announcer or a
racist pig or ho
sadly both oriented up yes but there's
satirical okay we're back in 60 seconds
with David King
you
David Koechner still here with us on the
Rich Eisen show again be part of one of
the best celebrity charity weekends
coming up in a couple weekends in Kansas
City Oh maze dot-com slash big slick you
get to hang out on the field of Kauffman
Stadium in Kansas City play softball
with the celebrities then hang out with
them for a two night stay it's just a
blast and you raise money for Children's
Mercy Hospital there that that is a
place that's heaven on earth for sick
kids so david koechner your thoughts on
the trade up by the Chiefs yep to get
Patrick mahomes well for the quarterback
spot for the future we assumed in case
tonight and so there had to be a deal
look these guys will all have greater
Minds than I do about this thing clearly
they saw something and you never know
it's always a gamble but now we have the
good news is we have time to wait dr.
drew because alex is not done and he
comes to big slick to I know he comes to
the yes he's come to the the Saturday
night show yeah right and what a great
guy he's a good dude what a great guy he
is a real good dude yeah I hope I always
hope nothing but great things for him so
it hurts when you know you've got a gret
draft a quarterback at some point you've
got to have somebody in there so now
you're gonna have a guy in comes a
larger system and he'll be ready in a
couple years the interesting thing about
that is that this year you know if they
thought they were if Reid was trading up
for somebody they could have gone to
Sean Watson who kind of fits the McNab
type West Coast offense mold or a
gunslinger Favre like who Reid had when
he was in Green Bay driving people crazy
he went with the Favre gunslinger
driving people crazy well I meant right
there because a guy like Favre kind of
makes the bibs also fix Alex Smith mold
because he scrambles and he's a
playmaker makes it you know you can't
you had to defend a couple different
ways right so maybe is that part of the
strategy it could be I don't know but
it's going to be fascinating to see play
out at opening night in New England what
is it really yeah yeah but it ended in
England yeah what do you think about
them apples well we're gonna win that's
what I think it's all I know we got some
Patriots fans here in the room and God
bless you
you've had enough let's don't get piggy
let's go
things you hear the ring that they
created to celebrate the last
championship which was just a few months
ago has 283 diamonds in it because they
were down 28 to 3
I was so incredible so if you're Bob
Kraft you're fortunate you weren't down
like 35 to 3 every ring has this you
know is that correct I think that should
be the way to go like you come back the
number of rings that you have is how far
down in the score you were that wouldn't
be bad that would not be bad I'm
grateful unless you're down 35 31 then
all of a sudden it's not a ring that
you're getting some sort of Franklin
Mint on your hand right all right would
you care to be my help in this uh-oh a
new show that this new game that will
either be one and done sort of like the
match game taint game that we had going
to say I'm always nervous to play they
have a game show with you at me but I
can't really work blue because you know
we're online we're on live radio
simulcast to it could be kids in the car
will be respect okay let's go a Chris
law it will be either you'll say the
name of a player and it will either be a
player that was just drafted in the
Major League Baseball Draft this week
yeah or a qualifier for the United
States Open that is just in the midst of
the first round correct that is correct
and we're calling this game what are we
calling this game uh well we have a drop
for this goal vertically you hit that
guy you shouldn't have been standing the
US Open qualifier just a bit outside he
tried to corner in this or MLB draft
prospect
very good nice package I like to keep my
folding package okay well we're talking
about what they just played right yeah
okay very good
I should not be the one keeping on
course there's no there's no rhyme or
reason to this I think the way this will
go down is I'm going to throw out a name
yes and you Rich Eisen the new Chris
Brockman will say what you think they're
designated sport is okay open qualifiers
first or draft prospect on the first one
you will go first rich okay second one
he'll go first
Oh get the assistance of mr. Koechner
generally left thank you um first name
I'm going to throw out there
Gooch Taylor there's no question is
hailer Gooch you never know it could be
like some some some kid who is a scratch
golfer when he was growing up in the
south
no you go get on that that's you want to
talk about a perfect baseball named
Taylor Gooch all right we from the from
this spot where David Koechner is on my
left the way you're looking at me he's
actually on my actual right but that's
okay jammer right okay very good we go
baseball brought them what do you say
yeah I say baseball as well law
pull up with you and your US qualifier
for the US Open where we know where he's
from we don't have many details well the
details we all have here say that this
person even exists as you said about the
charity you just type in the google
it'll tell you what you need to know
about tell Taylor's huge oh where is he
on the leaderboard right now we're still
a good slate at Oklahoma State Danny
Hill a group from Oklahoma State didn't
also play baseball Wow number two Wow
brockman Europe first time this one here
if you want to chime in go for it
Walker the week Walker League great golf
game if you walk also baseball walk a
lot of really main involvements his
nickname is cart Walker we does sound
like a Texas
golfer but I'm gonna say baseball what
do you think character well I was trying
to think did I get fooled by the name
growler yeah you got fooled by good show
while your Walker sounds like a family
name and often times golfers have a
pedigree of of course it does sound like
Walker Lee the fourth right doesn't it
okay we're going to go US Open qualifier
from this center here Rich Eisen
Koechner one yeah US Open qualifier okay
let's go back to the names here Tanner
how rich you are
Tanner how it sounds like a favor
doesn't it and now I did that seems
unquote well Tanner again Tanner how can
or how kiss a big I'm going to go up if
you don't mind I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
solo on this one gave yes I'm gonna go
baseball player Tanner Houk is
definitely a baseball player I agree
Tanner Hawk baseball what do you got for
me do you have a reason why you agreed
it's kind of like Justin Smoak it just
kind of sounds like asphalt yeah yeah yo
check out the 24th pick and this year's
MLB dress for the Boston lips ah ah
doesn't know who is first round okay you
know like I would live where I would
okay okay let's go with another name
here cameron champ cameron champ not
Jeff Garlin and I've got champ kind
helping me out here progress you better
choose this correctly oh god am i up
first
yes I'm gonna say golf cameron champ
what do you think David Koechner it
sounds about again I'm just going about
named Cameron champ what do you think
baseball what do you think don't I take
golf okay we say golf over here too
what do you got we're tied up at one one
apiece Brockman is correct
wait no nice goal he says he said
baseball yeah they're golf you're up to
Oh rich AIA knowledge champ kind over
there I fit golf but I get it right and
Richard Green is gone right so where's
the same two to one do two one how do
you even order you're still
personal ad okay blah blah this is a
Thompson of public Thompson now they're
gonna make us think you're gonna make us
thickness here you're gonna make us
think Bubba Watson is a golfer so Bubba
Thompson's of fluffy golfer I'm going to
say Bubba Thompson was a draftee in the
major league baseball drew I was going
to say it sounds like he it's a
misdirect and you wouldn't think golf
but I will go with you're gonna say
baseball over here at Brockman yeah that
was my gut instinct to Bubba Thompson
baseball what he got Brock Robert he got
well yeah it's baseball
okay I I was hoping you guys would go
where what was and where is he draft
26th pick of the Texas Rangers he's an
outfielder from high school out of
Mobile Alabama
Wow high school all right this is it
like either we win or you've got to give
us a tiebreaker name okay well reach
ready got a lot of reading and Nemeth
Joaquin Nieman you guys are
flabbergasted you got that drop Mike do
you think he's baseball you think he's
baseball hey I'm gonna say Joaquin
Nieman well it's your turn okay sorry
why Hillary gun you know control again
you can't pronounce where they work
again mr. Neiman what just me and why
can't you print on something I struggle
with walking a lot what is it chuckling
Joaquin what walk queen oh my god I'm
gonna take golf do we we could just say
golf just to win it doesn't matter what
we say we win right well no if we see if
we're wrong we go to a face-off named
David Koechner what do you think Neiman
wonky Neiman walkie Neiman I think he's
a golfer mister I feel like there's two
he's a golfer yeah yes that makes him a
golfer right he's a golf yeah I do have
an ultimate tiebreaker named for what is
it anyway though it's not necessarily
special although the fourth who is it
Davis Love divorce Davis Love the fourth
we wouldn't pulled that one out unless
he was drafted by baseball because it's
very obvious okay we say baseball
no it's golf because do three is
caddying for Davis Love the fourth Oh
the forces in the u.s. open too bad too
bad Brockman we are the winners so first
and probably only ever baseball prospect
but you already knew no you guys already
won
no but you already knew the answer he
already did know the images I search as
a pro it's not I just knew it you just
know it ah but please keep playing that
via some but we have some nice parting
gifts for you Chris Brockman thank you
for playing we appreciate that he won
the trip and thank you David Koechner
love having you here an honor to play
all amazed calm / big slick to be part
of one of the best celebrity charity
weekends going around big slick KC on
Twitter just like at David Koechner on
Twitter good to see you sir Republic the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to